hey henry how you doing i'm good thanks
morgan how are you
i'm great well congratulations on season
two reviews are out people are loving
this season which must feel so good for
you
what are you excited for the fans to see
with this season because season one
connected with people who love the games
the books and people who had never heard
of these characters before i mean it
became a phenomenon
uh for me the
i'm interested and excited to see
whatever people think it's um for me
it's always a fascination to go online
when the show comes out or when anything
i'm in comes out and
and read what people have to say because
there's always going to be a spectrum of
opinions and as soon as you separate the
um
the ones which are driven by a narrative
then you can actually find a really
really good set of opinions all the way
from negative to positive and that's the
kind of stuff which
which i'm excited to read so i'm excited
to see what
everything whatever what people think
about everything because it's more than
just one piece it's always
it's um a a culmination of pieces and so
i
i just want to hear what everyone has to
say and i want everyone to be honest
because that's the only way we can get
better
yeah well something that i love so much
about season two is we get to see more
of geralt which is exciting i mean don't
get me wrong season one's great uh man a
few words we've got some grunts we got
some f-bombs but we really get to uh
really get connected to this character
in season two why was that so important
for you
i campaigned really hard for geralt's um
from the book to exist in the show a bit
more
actively uh the girl from the books is
sort of the source material
he's
yes he is grumpy and petulant at times
and he's got a a really good sense of
humor too but he's intellectual and he's
wise and he's an amateur philosopher and
and he has this emotionality to him he's
a three-dimensional extremely
interesting character
and i wanted to really campaign hard to
bring that out i didn't want him to just
be this antagonistic monosyllabic
character um i wanted him to evolve and
represent that character more and it's
difficult to do because uh the vision of
the show is is particular this is
lauren's version of the story as well uh
but it's it's all about
i just made those little changes here
and there to to have him
have him have a a deeper vocabulary and
so even if he's not monologuing as much
as we see him in the books even if the
storylines and plots don't necessarily
allow him to to drive stuff in the same
way as they do in the books
it's we we
the the level of intellect that he has
and that if he's not if he's not doing
those things at least we uh are
representing the character as true as
truly as possible
oh i absolutely agree um and i love that
aspect of it so much another part that's
so fun is the father-daughter
relationship between geralt and siri and
sarah doesn't always listen to him which
is really entertaining for us to watch
how much did you like exploring that
relationship uh yeah it was um it there
there's definitely some funny aspects
there it's um it's a quite a it's a bit
more modernized um in the sense that uh
i think it started off as a little bit
of um you're not my real dad kind of
thing yeah and
i wanted to i wanted to push
i wanted to push that girl wasn't going
to be antagonistic and yes she may have
these moments of being uh
emotional or upset or
or antagonistic herself but she's been
through trauma just recently gareth's
been through loads of trauma himself but
i wanted to make sure that that we
represented a girl who was understanding
of her trauma rather than just
you know blindly wandering around trying
to be a dad instead being a protector
and having to take on this this
father-like role and um i think freyr
did an amazing job of of towing that
line between someone who has been
through trauma someone who's hiding what
they feel is a secret and also someone
who is growing to love and trust this
this protector type who
she only does that because
her grandmom told her to do it said go
find this guy
and and that's the only connection she
has so and it's i think freya did an
amazing job yeah absolutely uh congrats
on season two uh i loved it so much it's
so beautiful holy every scene so
beautiful thank you thank you very much
you